[Music]
you're looking at a really happy mister
this is corporal baker
home on his first furlough in over a
year
he's a smart clean-cut guy and he's a
good soldier
he's going to enjoy these days with his
family
right now it's a good warm feeling
walking down main street exchanging nods
and handshakes with the people who've
known him since he was a kid
baker would never get by without a visit
to the old drugstore
for a coke and a little chatter with
anyone who might be around
just like the days before he went in the
army
[Music]
that's good to be home
sleeping late no details no formations
no marching
taking it easy
money on the hip
faces that he knows
hmm
what's this
one that he doesn't know
now this looks like a girl a man could
go for
not just for the fun but for keeps
if only he could get to talk to her
well
he could
it wasn't hard
because she wanted a straw and it
happened they were right in front of him
and that's the way it all started
it was a nice beginning
but it was only the beginning
she put the finishing touch to baker's
furlough and made it wonderful
[Music]
she was all the man dreams about
gentle and clean
she liked the simple things
baker did too
she didn't drink
she didn't like juke joints
she lived in the next block
her mother and father were good people
she talked soft and she seemed well
educated like baker he enjoyed every
moment they spent together
you can't blame baker for enjoying those
moments
especially since she loved him
she told him
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
it was a wonderful furlough
and it was tough it ever had to end
but you know how the army is about those
things
they were going to write each other
often though
and that would take some of the edge off
being a part
you sure were lucky corporal baker
and all because a sweet girl came along
and wanted a straw for her coat
[Music]
well
sit there corporal baker and have a good
time while you can
sit there and dream about the 10 days
you had in heaven
because in a few hours
you're going to find out just what sort
of a furlough you really had
yeah
ten wonderful days in heaven
[Music]
good gonorrhea baker
gonorrhea
why i don't know how i do
you had a dirty woman no sir girl back
home she wasn't any prostitute
have you known her alone
i i met her the day i got home sir on
the street or in a bar
well i don't mess around with street
walks i met her in the drugstore was you
pick up
no sir i just met her that's all
and you had her that night
no sir
the next night and you didn't use it
robin
she was afraid of them sir or a pro kid
no sir and you didn't go to a pro
station she looked clean so she looked
clean all over not on the inside corvo
where you touched her she was filthy and
diseased
that girl yours was just a pickup
just what does it mean to have gonorrhea
well take this man
he used to be a star
athlete he caught gonorrhea and went to
a drug store instead of a medical doctor
don't you take chances on being crippled
like this
and this is the kind of thing gonorrhea
means
furthermore it doesn't feel any better
than it looks
now some dumb joes think gonorrhea is
caused by a strain
like lifting the rear end of a jeep
or getting tired on a long march
or knocking yourself out on kp
or sliding into second
well that's playing crazy
the only strain that gives you gonorrhea
is the strain of chasing after a woman
well you know what corporal baker's
doing here in the dispensary waiting for
treatments what's this other guy doing
here
he's private anderson
in the same outfit as bakers
he's more of a playboy than baker
but he's not a bad soldier
he's just out for the laughs and the
more of them the better
he looks pretty unhappy right now
but imagine it's a week earlier
he didn't look so unhappy then
he just been paid and tonight he's gonna
cut himself a slice of good time
anderson's idea of a good time is
drinking and girls
he's had months of marching in kp and
this is his night to howl
well the prophylactic station's happy
he'll be coming back here for a pro
after he's had his fun
sure anderson will be stopping in at the
pro station
or anyway that's what he thinks now
while he's sober and can still think
which isn't for long in joints like this
one
it's the old setup girls a jukebox and a
bar
especially the bar with lots of liquor
to lift you until you're way up in the
clouds
[Music]
anderson was definitely out for a good
time
but he didn't think he'd run into
anything this good
she certainly was good looking
[Music]
damn sight better looking than anything
he expected to find in a place like this
[Music]
sure he knew she was a [__] so what
pores are supposed to keep clean aren't
they
lots of places even have laws to make
them keep clean
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
now that's what anderson calls having a
good time
and when it was over it was time to take
a pro because it's no good unless you
take it right away
but anderson didn't exactly feel like
leaving
not when he could lie around and have a
smoke and
then maybe for another two bucks
well he was out for a good time wasn't
he
and that's just what he was going to get
and maybe a little more he wasn't out
for
what made you think she might be clean
anderson she was a prostitute that's it
sir i figured if being a prostitute was
a job she'd have to keep clean
well maybe she'd like to
but she can't if she takes on men one
after another any man with a couple of
dollars
but she had a car that said she was in
good health and probably a week old
but even if it had been only an hour old
it still wouldn't mean a thing
she could have had a man with a vd five
minutes before she had you and pass his
germs on to you
yes sir
you know you might have stayed well if
you're going to the pro station
i will next time sir there won't be any
next time for quite a while anderson
you've got syphilis
sweat it out anderson
but if it's any comfort to you
you're lucky
some men aren't smart enough to go to a
doctor when they get a case
this man for example
he was a hero in the last war
but the wounds that have kept him in and
out of the hospital ever since 1918
weren't from combat
he caught syphilis from a [__] overseas
and never went on sick call
this man looks as healthy as anybody
but the little syphilis germs have been
making his blood bad
boring into his heart for a long time
and one day
the heart just quits
yes
he looked healthy
but that's because syphilis doesn't do
much advertising
take a look at this one
he's really blown his top
when he talks he doesn't make much sense
and sometimes he runs wild and has to be
held in bed with straps so he won't hurt
anyone
the syphilis germs got into his brain
is your memory all right
so i can remember anything it ever
happen
let me test your memory
by giving you three words to remember
other words are pink
broadway
and 46.
would be
i'll ask you what they were in a moment
is your speech all right
any do you stumble over big words
say after me
third
writing artillery brigade
turn
bragging about say it again did running
it will be great then writing that would
be great that's enough
now what are the three words that i ask
you to remember
i don't know
i can't remember
this poor fellow is in mighty bad shape
and all because of
there are several venereal diseases but
the most common two are syphilis
[Music]
and gonorrhea
some people call syphilis bad blood ox
louise a case
the dogs and so on some people call
gonorrhea the clap a strain the running
range a dose
they all mean venereal disease
vd
it's a bad deal and it's catching
and you catch it only one way from a
woman
doesn't matter if she's a high school
girl or a jew joint girl
insider they may be sores full of
crawling little germs
like these wiggling syphilis germs that
stick to your skin like molasses
you get these germs and the gonorrhea
germs only from a woman
but you don't get them if you use a
condom
or rubber
and if you put it on before you even
touch a girl
remember
if she tells you she doesn't want to use
a rubber she's up to no good
if she's afraid it might come off and
get inside her someplace so that she'll
need an operation to get it out she's
just crazy
even if you tried you couldn't force it
inside any place where it could do harm
so don't let any woman talk you out of
using one
the next best thing is to take a pro at
the pro station
but take it as soon as possible after
you've had your piece the way they do it
now it doesn't hurt and it doesn't take
more than a few minutes
it's a fine way not to catch a vd
there's been talk by some stupid guys
that a pro destroys your manhood and if
you have too many of them you won't be
able to have sex anymore
well anybody who thinks that is just
ignorance
a pro doesn't hurt anything except germs
another good way not to get vd is to use
the army's new pro kit
it was thought of just for men in the
army and it works
it consists of a tube of ointment
a sub cloth
a piece of tissue
and some instructions now here's all you
have to do
right after you've had sex
take a leak
and wash yourself with a soap cloth
then take the top off the tube
and squeeze one fourth of it inside
doesn't hurt and it doesn't sting you
can't even feel it
squeeze the rest of the tube onto your
fingers and rub it all over
it kill syphilis and gonorrhea before
they can get started doing their damage
but those are the ways of keeping clean
the condom or rubber
the pro station
and the pro kit
but the simplest and best way of all is
to
stay away from women
[Music]
your army doctors know bd
so do your officers and non-cums
listen to them when they teach you about
syphilis and gonorrhea they're trying to
help you
they want us to become the healthiest
people in the world
don't be afraid to go on sick call as
soon as you think you've caught bd
don't be afraid and don't be ashamed
you won't be punished no gigs no loss of
pay no loss of rank all the army wants
to do is cure you
and sends you back to civilian life
healthier than you've ever been
you must keep yourself clean
[Music]
keeping clean means keeping healthy
and it was good health to beat the
germans before the war even started
this is joe lewis taking a few pokes at
hitler's boy max schmaling
all of joe's training was to get in
proper condition proper health
this massacre you're looking at couldn't
have taken place if joe hadn't kept
himself clean
remember the last olympic games in
berlin back in 36
a lot of our boys invaded germany long
before the first american soldier went
down to the induction center
and they all knew the value of good
health and of staying clean
that was owens in the dashes and broad
jump
[Applause]
and johnson in the high jump
and woodruff and edwards in the 800
meters
and ralph metcalf was one of the men who
helped pile up our big score
here he is now in a little bit of a
hurry
metcalf sent the stars and stripes up
above the swastika and rising sun so
often the hitler and hirohito should
have taken the hint right there and quit
and here's lieutenant ralph metcalf
himself
winning a race against tough competition
means more than just being fast on your
feet
it's training off of the field as well
as on that gives you that extra speed
when you need it most i figure that
life's that way too the drive that helps
you to break a record comes from being
in shape
perfect shape
i don't say that i've won races just
because i didn't fool around with women
but it certainly helped
remember military fitness not only
includes technical and mental fitness
but physical fitness as well and that
means not taking chances with women
that'll be good for you and for all of
us
but maybe you don't want to stay healthy
and keep yourself clean
maybe you want to hop in bed with one
gal after another
well maybe you'd like to hop into the
same boat with these men
this man thought he was killing the vd
germs by rubbing whiskey on his rod
after he had a pickup
whiskey doesn't kill anything
except
the brain
this man didn't use a rubber
because he'd been told it didn't feel so
good with a rubber
well
what he's got now really doesn't feel
good
and this man
he had to pay a terrible price for
catching syphilis
he married the girl he loved
and passed the germs on to her
pretty soon she had a baby
it had syphilis too
it would have been better dead
this is paul robson who enjoys the
respect and recognition of the entire
world
from his college days when he was an
all-american end
through his great career as singer actor
and world traveler
mr robson has done as much good for our
people as any man alive
listen to him
what you've been seeing here makes a lot
of sense
20 years ago we didn't have pictures
like this
for hours we had to sit and listen to
the coach lecture
he gave it to us hot and heavy and we
took it
because if you want to play football
you've got to have a healthy body
in fact if you want to do anything in
this world you've got to have a healthy
body
now this film is pretty frightening
yet it's not as frightening as a records
the war department has shown me on vd
i tell you we've got to do something
about this and we have the answer
you've seen it right here in this
picture
none of us will forget what we've
learned from this movie
but more important
let's not forget our responsibility to
our communities
our families and ourselves
we must defeat vd
[Music]
i